i'm
so backed up on features and it's stuff
that
i just don't want to over play i'm
talking about features from
big artists you know what i'm saying
well you just had a feature come out
with was it with her
yeah yeah which is [ __ ] crazy
i saw that happen like on twitter right
yeah
it's dope to see like the fruit will you
see that
that happen you reply uh-huh yeah and
then the song comes out
yeah now for sure i feel like everybody
i ever hit up didn't hit me back like
everybody i ever
tweet everybody that i went after like
you know what i'm saying
didn't hit me back and just got with me
like i feel like that's why
everything just be natural like kind of
how did everything with her go down did
she just send you a record or was it
something you know we got in the studio
so you guys actually got in together
yeah we made like four workers that's
amazing
that's very rare nowadays yeah no for
sure
usually it's like yo here's the mp3
there's an open thing do what you do on
it send it back yeah
i'd rather wait before do that because i
just be like you know what i'm saying
i'm more of a creator especially when
it's an artist like that i like to get
in and like
feel feel vibes and stuff like that so
so you guys got four records
yeah i don't think all of them coming
out though i just know we we cut we cut
four records
uh she chose one for her man i chose one
for mine so she's on the album
that's big man what was her process like
and like like because i feel like you're
do you do you do the melody first then
punch in the lyrics or like like you
know what i'm saying me i i do
i do i write the lyrics in the mirror i
mean i do the
lyrics in the middle at the same time i
just get on the mic and just
go so the paradise song uh it was just
more like i was already working on the
idea when she walked in the studio
filming and when she walked in i kind of
was like we're just gonna
just go to the next song like work on
something first but she was like oh i
liked i liked that finished that so i
just
finished it and then we just got the
collab and working on